oh hello I didn't see you there
okay I did I saw you I actually I turned
on the phone with my finger by pushing
it right here but then I tried to do one
of those casual you know oh but I knew
you were there
so that's awkward I just you should have
done it and committed to it or not done
it but I sort of did it and then look at
the mess we're in right now
I apologize we've got a great show
tonight
like every other person in the world in
my business I'm coming to you from my
home with a bust of Teddy Roosevelt
we're all the same at the end of the day
love tonight's show I really do and I'll
tell you why not because I'm part of the
show I'm my least favorite part
lin-manuel miranda is joining us
thrilled to have him he's so talented
such a great guy we'll have a good time
also I do enjoy trying to entertain
people it's something that has always
motivated me and big part of the show
for me has always been starting off the
program with a couple of jokes of course
I like the back and forth with Andy
Richter so we tried this the other day I
wanted Andy to be responding live to my
quips and problem was his internet was
down well guess what I told him get it
fixed and we're gonna do it today and
it's down again Andy has really crappy
internet but I told him that's okay just
pre record your reactions and we'll drop
them in that seems to work pretty well
okay so what I'm gonna do now is tell
some jokes and then we'll hear Andy
Richter's pre-recorded reactions so we
get some of that classic Cohn and Andy
banter okay got some jokes in hot off
the press from the writers here we go
well both New York and San Francisco
have canceled their upcoming gay pride
parades
officials say for now the safest way to
celebrate being gay is to tweet about
Vanderpump rules
Wow great joke Conan in the Northeast
there's a
thirty percent drop in air pollution
that could be seen from space and in
Boston there is a 60 percent drop in
alcoholism that can also be seen from
space oh yeah I had an uncle like that
hey one of the craziest conspiracies out
there right now is that the founder of
Microsoft Bill Gates created Co vid 19
yeah yeah
today Gates said believe me if I had
created kovat 19 it would have crashed a
long time ago nope and of course just on
a personal sad note it's been one year
now today since I lost my precious cat
pebbles passed away keep going keep
going huh anyway as we all know the
corona virus has changed the way we live
I thought right now we take a second and
pay tribute to those things we're gonna
have to say goodbye to
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
all right we have a terrific show
tonight lin-manuel miranda is going to
be joining us and if you feel like
giving we are suggesting partners in
health coronavirus response fund good
place to give